Katrina:  我住西直门
Katrina: I live in Xizhimen.
Nicous: 不是我讲的是那个动物园
Nicous: No, I’m talking about that zoo.
Lucia:然后我最近刚好比较闲
Lucia: And I happen to be quite free lately.
Katrina:  野生动物园
Katrina: The wildlife zoo.
Nicous: 嗯
Nicous: Yeah.
Jack: 然后就来玩一下
Jack: So we just came to hang out.
Nicous: 我草才跟我说
Nicous: My friend just told me.
Katrina:  真假啊你说24号
Katrina: Seriously, you mean the 24th?
Katrina:  我以为我之前跟你说过呢
Katrina: I thought I told you before.
Nicous: 他男的女的
Nicous: Is it a guy or a girl?
Katrina: 他是谁啊
Katrina: Who is it?
Lucia:其实我还以为
Lucia: Actually, I thought...
Nicous: 我学长他问我
Nicous: My senior asked me...
Lucia:我刚开始还以为
Lucia: At first, I thought...
Lucia:小红书难道是你发的吗
Lucia: Was it you who posted on Little Red Book?
Nicous: 他问我
Nicous: He asked me...
Jake: 嗯有什么差别
Jake: Hmm, what's the difference?
Jake: 反正字是我写对
Jake: Anyway, I wrote the text, right?
Katrina:  为啥要凑人啊
Katrina: Why do we need more people?
Lucia:主要是我感觉你不是像
Lucia: Mainly because I feel like you don't seem...
还得摇人是什么意思
Katrina: What does it mean to need more people?
Katrina:  还得摇人是什么意思
下周再有空就去动物园
Voice: If we're free next week, let's go to the zoo.
感觉气质像小红书的
Voice: Feels like the vibe of Little Red Book.
哦哦气质不对是吧
Voice: Oh, oh, the vibe is off, right?
动物园吗
Voice: The zoo?
Jake: 啊哦哦
Jake: Ah, oh, oh.
Jake: 气质不对是吧
Jake: The vibe is off, right?
还有谁啊
Voice: Who else?
Jake: 不应该有小红书
Jake: There shouldn't be a Little Red Book.
Nicous: 我一个朋友
Nicous: A friend of mine.
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia:我不是这个意思
Lucia: That's not what I meant.
Nicous: 还得摇一个人
Nicous: Still need another person.
Nicous: 因为他想让我不单独捞着
Nicous: Because he doesn't want me to be alone.
Lucia:因为感觉您比较卡皮扒拉是小红书
Lucia: Because it feels like you fit the Little Red Book style.
Tasha: 但是无所谓啊
Tasha: But it doesn't matter.
Lucia:您的气质要这个
Lucia: Your vibe needs to be like this.
Nicous: 他们俩情侣你们俩情侣
Nicous: They're a couple, and you two are a couple.
Jake: 小红书是一个J
Jake: Little Red Book is a J.
Nicous: 他俩情侣玩为什么要带你啊
Nicous: Why would they bring you along if they're a couple?
Katrina: 他俩情侣玩为啥要带你啊
Katrina: Why would they bring you along if they're a couple?
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Nicous: 因为他俩单独出去
Nicous: Because when they go out alone...
Lucia:我们最近使用这个理论
Lucia: We've been using this theory lately.
Nicous: 他俩还没有正式成为情侣
Nicous: They're not officially a couple yet.
Lucia:来合理跨界的各种行为
Lucia: To rationalize various cross-border actions.
Katrina:  哦哦就带你就相当于
Katrina: Oh, oh, bringing you along is like...
Jake: 对对对太合理了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's totally reasonable.
Jack: 我这个我好像是看出来了一点
Jack: I think I kind of figured it out.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh.
Nicous: 都是北邮的
Nicous: They're all from Beiyou.
Nicous: 哈哈你被四个北邮人包围
Nicous: Haha, you're surrounded by four Beiyou people.
Katrina:  我这辈子跟北邮人脱不了关系
Katrina: I can't seem to get away from Beiyou people my whole life.
Nicous: 注意乘坐野生动物园
Nicous: Watch out while riding the wildlife safari.
Lucia:野生动物园
Lucia: Wildlife safari?
Jack: 又诞生了什么新的野生动物园
Jack: What new wildlife safari has been created now?
Katrina:  如果23号去找那个北邮男生说清楚
Katrina: If we go find that Beiyou guy on the 23rd and talk it out...
Katrina:  如果我们俩在一起了
Katrina: If we end up together...
Katrina:  就多待在北京多待一天哦
Katrina: We'll stay in Beijing for an extra day.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Nicous: 噢
Nicous: Oh.
Katrina:  就是也是动物园
Katrina: It's like a zoo too.
Katrina:  然后他说他也去了
Katrina: And he said he would go too.
Nicous: 原来他是置中一下
Nicous: So he just wants to balance things out.
大家快去助攻一下他也去
Everyone: Go support him, he's going too.
Jake: 他也去他是
Jake: He's going too, he is...
Katrina:  他 不是
Katrina: No, he's not.
Jake: 为什么去
Jake: Why is he going?
Katrina:  他是他他有一个学长跟他
Katrina: He has a senior with him.
Katrina:  学长跟他的暧昧对象还没有在一
Katrina: The senior and his crush aren't together yet.
Katrina:  起但是又不想太尴尬就摇了他
Katrina: But he doesn't want it to be too awkward, so he called him.
Katrina:  然后他又不想让他落单
Katrina: And he didn't want him to be alone.
Katrina:  就是说他可以再喊个朋友
Katrina: So he said he could call another friend.
Katrina:  他说如果我我俩承认
Katrina: He said if we admit it...
Katrina:  他说他不介意他再带一对情侣
Katrina: He wouldn't mind bringing another couple.
Katrina:  就这意思
Katrina: That's what he meant.
Katrina:  他们有车去
Katrina: They have a car to go.
Jack: 我还以为说他是来这个专门作乐的
Jack: I thought he came here just for fun.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  哈哈他还挺抽象的
Katrina: Haha, he's quite abstract.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 哈哈谢彬竹很好玩啊我觉得
Katrina: Haha, Xie Binzhu is really fun, I think.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:工作不饱和啊关键是
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: Hilarious.
Jack: 你这都1111期了还不饱和啊
Jack: You've reached episode 1111 and it's still not saturated?
Jack: 啊多次啊
Jack: That's a lot.
Jack: 你觉得这领导说的是人话吗
Jack: Do you think the boss is even making sense?
Lucia:领导说的那必须是人话呀
Lucia: Well, the boss has to be making sense, right?
Lucia:你说话咋不是人话呢想什么呢啊
Lucia: How come what you say never makes sense? What are you thinking?
Jake:今至少今天还是
Jake: At least today still
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay
Lucia:至少到明天也得是
Lucia: At least until tomorrow
Jake: 对至少到明天还是
Jake: Yeah, at least until tomorrow
Jake: 至少还是当一天人
Jake: At least still be a decent person for one more day
Jack: 至少还有一天嘛
Jack: At least there's one more day
Jack: 对
Jack: Yeah
其他人:可以可以
Jake: 后天再说
Jake: Let's talk about it the day after
Jack: 哇
Jack: Wow
Jack: 贵活动真有意思啊
Jack: This event is really interesting
Jake: 以前看过这个吗
Jake: Have you seen this before?
Jake: 看过这段吗
Jake: Seen this part?
Jack: 不跟我去啊
Jack: No, you didn't go with me?
Jake: 你你那时候应该在屋里边在
Jake: You should have been inside at that time
Katrina: 看了看了
Katrina: Yeah, I saw it
Jake: 哦看过了
Jake: Oh, you saw it
Katrina: 就接我的那个是吗
Katrina: The one right after mine, right?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jack: 这个屏幕的主意是谁想出来的
Jack: Who came up with the idea for this screen?
Jake: 你说小包吗
Jake: Are you talking about Little Bao?
Jack: 这个欢迎
Jack: This welcome
Jack: 大屏幕啊
Jack: The big screen
这我我2022年
This, in 2022
Jake: 这我我2022年
Jake: This, in 2022
Jake: 在在在在
Jake: In, in, in
Jake: 这个在特拉维夫
Jake: In Tel Aviv
Jack: 这个在W202 ECCD best student bag
Jack: This was at the W202 ECCD best student bag
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jack: 不是
Jack: No
Jake: 这是这么回事
Jake: So here's the deal
Jake: 这推特上面啊
Jake: On Twitter
Jake: 是这么回事
Jake: Here's the deal
Jake: 是这个计算机会议啊
Jake: At this computer conference
Jake: 那那帮研究员他们一边开会
Jake: Those researchers, while having a meeting
Jake: 然后大家觉得闲无聊开了一个
Jake: They all felt bored and started a
Jake: 就是就是就是蹦迪
Jake: It's like, it's like, it's like clubbing.
Jake: 在会场蹦迪
Jake: Clubbing at the venue.
Jake: 然后我就带了一个这个包
Jake: And then I brought this bag.
Jake: 然后过去上面就就就晃悠晃晃那个
Jake: And then I went over there and just, just, just swung it around.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Like this.
Jake: 那我给你给你看吧
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake: 我很难描述这个事情
Jake: It's hard to describe it.
Lucia:这么久远的记录你居然还能很快找到
Lucia: You can still find such old records so quickly.
Jake: 推特哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Twitter, hahaha.
Lucia:哦行吧行吧打扰了
Lucia: Oh, alright, alright, sorry to bother you.
Jack: 我去
Jack: Oh man.
Lucia:我还以为他文件分更别类就放好了呢
Lucia: I thought he had his files organized neatly.
Jake: 那你可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on now.
Jack: 不是不是
Jack: No, no.
我说作为一个搞计算机的
Jake: I mean, as a computer expert.
Jack: 作为一个搞计算机的
Jack: As a computer expert.
Jack: 不应该都有一个技术
Jack: Shouldn't you have some sort of system?
男嘉宾:那个二楼的GoPro的卡要拆吗
Male Guest: Should we remove the GoPro card on the second floor?
Jake: 要拆要拆都拆
Jake: Yes, remove it, remove them all.
Jake: 全部拆掉吧
Jake: Take them all out.
Jack: 你不应你不应该有全套gate吗
Jack: Shouldn't you have a full set of gates?
Jake: 有啊但是很多上不了gate哈
Jake: Yes, but many can't access the gate, haha.
Jack: 你都干了些什么呀
Jack: What exactly have you done?
Jake:明天录明天录对
Jake: Recording tomorrow, recording tomorrow, yes.
Jake: 好知道哪了
Jake: Alright, I know where it is.
Violet: 加进来然后他里面的那个参考文献
Violet: Add it in, and then the references inside.
Violet: 都要重新重新的整理起来
Violet: They all need to be reorganized.
Violet: 先把这个这个参考文献找出来
Violet: First, find these references.
男嘉宾:谢彬竹 谢彬竹 谢彬竹
Male Guest: Xie Binzhu, Xie Binzhu, Xie Binzhu.
Violet: 好加到参考文献里面
Violet: Alright, add it to the references.
Violet: 然后把这边的这个序号的改一下
Violet: And then change this number over here.
Violet: 就这部分
Violet: Just this part.
Violet: 然后内容就完成
Violet: Then the content is complete.
Jake: 来找着了
Jake: Found it.
Jake: 就在这个地方
Jake: Right here.
Jack: 这个这个壁纸是什么
Jack: What is this wallpaper?
Jack: :打个盒子这个好好吃啊
Jack: This boxed meal is so delicious.
Jake: 对哎我靠这声音怎么整啊
Jake: Right, oh man, how do I fix this sound?
Jack: 哦牛
Jack: Oh, awesome.
Lucia:牛啊
Lucia: Awesome.
Lucia:这声是你换的
Lucia: Did you change this sound?
Jake:对对am在妮子yell也要换
Jake: Yes, yes, am at Nizi yell also needs to be changed.
Nicous: am在妮子
Nicous: Am at Nizi
男嘉宾:哎我们只用到二楼的吗
Male Guest: Oh, are we only using the second floor?
Jake: 然后大概就是在大概就是那一天
Jake: And then basically it was like that day.
男嘉宾:谢彬竹
Male Guest: Xie Binzhu
Jake: 搞了一个这个包
Jake: Got this bag.
Jake: 然后上面一些跳舞就被人给举了起来
Jake: And then some people were dancing and got lifted up.
男嘉宾:我怎么感觉不够
Male Guest: Why do I feel it's not enough?
Jake: 对对对辛酸对哦
Jake: Yes, yes, it's bittersweet.
Katrina: 这是你吗
Katrina: Is this you?
Jake: 对这是我
Jake: Yes, this is me.
Jake: 我背了一个这个包去开会
Jake: I carried this bag to the meeting.
Jake: 然后被主办方给捕捉了
Jake: And then got captured by the organizers.
Jake: 到最后就火了一下
Jake: In the end, it went viral for a bit.
Jack: 你这么阔一个包
Jack: You carried such a big bag.
Katrina: 哇好帅啊
Katrina: Wow, so handsome.
Jake: 当时在拧那个牌子的时候
Jake: When I was twisting that sign,
Jake: 然后主办方拍了一张拍了一段
Jake: The organizers took a shot, took a video.
Jake: 就这个推特
Jake: This tweet,
Jake: 就是那个会议的最高点赞的一个推特
Jake: It was the most liked tweet of that meeting.
Jack: 对对严肃的会议
Jack: Yes, yes, a serious meeting.
Jack: 大家是看不好也不
Jack: Everyone couldn't help but laugh.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 对是这么回事
Jake: That's how it was.
Jack: 投上就好
Jack: Just cast your vote.
Jake: 就是玩
Jake: Just for fun.
Jake: 主要是看在什么地方开会
Jake: It mainly depends on where the meeting is held.
Jake: 然后再决定投不投
Jake: And then decide whether to vote or not.
Katrina:  你这包里天天装啥呢
Katrina: What do you carry in this bag every day?
Katrina:  一个男生天天带个包
Katrina: A guy carrying a bag every day.
Jake: 唉
Jake: Sigh
Katrina: 好看啊
Katrina: It's nice.
Katrina:  唉这蛋糕还能明天吃吗
Katrina: Hey, can this cake still be eaten tomorrow?
Jake:要关 要换了
Jake: It needs to be kept, needs to be changed.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 星巴克送
Katrina: Starbucks delivery.
Jake: 好 开工唉
Jake: Okay, let's start working.
Katrina:  这 哦 修硕
Katrina: Oh, Shure.
Katrina:  哎修硕不是要停了天走吗
Katrina: Hey, didn't Shure say he would stop and leave today?
Jake: 各位下班我开工
Jake: Everyone's off work, I'm starting.
Jake: 各位开工我开工
Jake: Everyone's starting work, I'm starting.
Lucia:老板上工了
Lucia: Boss is starting work.
Jake:哈哈老板上工
Jake: Haha, the boss is starting work.
Katrina:  修硕不是要回去吗
Katrina: Isn't Shure going back?
Jake:老板开始上工
Jake: The boss is starting work.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 老板要开工了
Jake: The boss is starting work.
Katrina:  感觉他就是蒙了有点
Katrina: Feels like he's a bit confused.
Jack: 老板摸了一天鱼了终于开始干活了
Jack: The boss has been slacking all day, finally starting to work.
Jake: 老板我也到夜里11点上班
Jake: The boss works until 11 PM.
Jake: 让你们11点下班
Jake: I let you guys off at 11.
Nicous: 这要关起来吗
Nicous: Should we close this?
Jake: 我来关我来关
Jake: I'll close it, I'll close it.
Nicous: 一楼的也没关那你
Nicous: The first floor isn't closed either, so you...
Katrina:  这个拿保鲜膜弄一下再放
Katrina: Wrap this with plastic wrap and then put it away.
男嘉宾:这只有手动吗
Male Guest: Is this manual only?
Katrina:  放进去不
Katrina: Should I put it in?
Jake: 不要手动不要手动
Jake: No manual, no manual.
Lucia:这放明天应该不会坏吧
Lucia: If we put it there, it shouldn't spoil by tomorrow, right?
Katrina:  但是感觉冰箱很多细菌
Katrina: But it feels like the fridge has a lot of bacteria.
Jake: 不要手动啊no手动
Jake: No manual, no manual.
Lucia:你不回吗我们准备休息了其实对
Lucia: Aren't you going back? We're about to rest, actually, yes.
Jake: 我好像关了我好像全关了but but 9没关
Jake: I think I closed it, I think I closed everything, but but 9 isn't closed.
男嘉宾:but
Male Guest: But...
男嘉宾:11也没关
Male Guest: 11 isn't closed either.
Jake: 哎呦我靠好好好稍等稍等
Jake: Oh my gosh, alright alright, hold on, hold on.
男嘉宾:只要亮的没关
Male Guest: Only the ones with lights are not closed.
Jake: 亮的就是没关
Jake: If it's lit, it's not closed.
男嘉宾:15也没关
Male Guest: 15 isn't closed either.
Jake: 那就是我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 怎么这么没关啊
Jake: Why are so many not closed?
Lucia:好好好先把这个送给你
Lucia: Alright, alright, I'll give this to you first.
Jake: 我先关9
Jake: I'll close 9 first.
Jake: 别别别着急no worry
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry, no worry.
Lucia:这个你挑一个吧
Lucia: You pick one of these.
Lucia:那个他要
Lucia: He wants that one.
Lucia:那个他要放在门口
Lucia: He wants to put that at the door.
男嘉宾:好的好的
Male Guest: Okay, okay.
男嘉宾:不要让他变成可怜的那个没有CP的
Male Guest: Don't let him be the poor one without a partner.
Lucia:今天他今天他还和CP拍了照是吧
Lucia: Today, he took pictures with CP, right?
男嘉宾:是的
Male Guest: Yes.
Lucia:然后看他们俩多可爱
Lucia: And look how cute they are.
还能再摆一天男嘉宾:
Male Guest: Can last another day.
Jack: 就多一天的CP寿命是吧
Jack: So another day of CP life, right?
Lucia:那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Lucia:一天也是天
Lucia: A day is still a day.
Lucia:这个这个这
Lucia: This, this, this...
Lucia:我们要给这个狗建立因果联系
Lucia:我和把它做出来了
Lucia: I made it together with it.
Lucia:就是突然消失
Lucia: It just suddenly disappeared.
Lucia:要一定要等到我们这个数据采集完之后
Lucia: We have to wait until we've collected all the data.
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Jake:好 好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia:要不然哎呀
Lucia: Otherwise, oh dear...
Lucia:这想不通
Lucia: I can't figure it out.
Lucia:怎么没了呢
Lucia: How did it disappear?
Jack: 七天没没白练
Jack: Seven days weren't wasted.
Jake: 好
Jake: Yeah.
Jack: 七天没白练
Jack: Seven days weren't wasted.
Jake:没白练
Jake: Totally worth it.
Katrina:  七天AI速成营
Katrina: Seven-day AI crash course.
Jack: AI速成营
Jack: AI crash course.
Jack: 我看是你的
Jack: I think it's yours.
Lucia:不是这感情这跟训练我似的
Lucia: Isn't this training like mine?
Jake: 哈哈哈是啊
Jake: Hahaha, it is.
Katrina: 7天AI
Katrina: Seven-day AI.
Jake: 咱现在有6个AI
Jake: Now we have six AIs.
Jack: 真的我觉得你比AI训练的成功
Jack: Honestly, I think you're more successful than the AI training.
Jake:AI其中一个
Jake: One of the AIs.
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Lucia:哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, right.
你你你比你比那个
You, you, you're more...
Jack: 我看见那个拆个TPT
Jack: I saw that disassembling a TPT.
Jack: 那玩意还成功一点
Jack: That thing's more successful.
Lucia:那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Lucia:拆TPT上七
Lucia: Disassembling TPT in seven.
Katrina:  七天零基础带你入门AI
Katrina: Seven days, no foundation, get you started with AI.
Jake:哈哈哈从入门到AI
Jake: Hahaha, from beginner to AI.
从入门到从入门到入土
From beginner to the grave.
Katrina: 哈哈哈从入门到入土
Katrina: Hahaha, from beginner to buried.
Jake: 从入门到入库
Jake: From beginner to stored.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈入库
Jake: Hahahaha, stored.
Jack: 入库像话吗
Jack: Stored? Is that even right?
Jack: 十
Jack: Ten.
Nicous: 十
Nicous: Ten.
男嘉宾:这我怎么收呢
Male Guest: How do I handle this?
Jake: 这个挪开把
Jake: Move this aside.
Jake: 哎你说这么使
Jake: Hey, how do you use this?
Jake: 上车
Jake: Get in the car.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Nicous: 这一天是几个G120G
Nicous: How many GBs is this for a day? 120GB?
Jake: 二五六
Jake: 256.
Jake: 今天得是二五六
Jake: Today it’s 256.
Jake: 明天一二八就行
Jake: Tomorrow, 128 will do.
Jake: 都是算好的
Jake: It's all calculated.
Jake: 我操我操
Jake: Damn, damn.
Katrina:  我摘了我要下班了
Katrina: I'm done, I'm getting off work.
Jake: 你往前采采吧
Jake: Move forward and pick.
Jake: 你要不
Jake: If you don’t...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 我来收充电宝
Jake: I’ll collect the power banks.
Jake: 每天都要
Jake: Every day needs it.
Jake: 你动了就要
Jake: If you use it, you need it.
Jake: 开始吃夜宵
Jake: Let’s start the midnight snack.
Jake: 夜宵时间
Jake: Snack time.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jack: 我看他们的意思是再点点
Jack: I think they want to order more.
Jake: 哈哈哈那不至于那不至于
Jake: Hahaha, no way, no way.
Jack: 是这意思吗
Jack: Is that what they mean?
Jake: 咱还有一些这些东西
Jake: We still have some of these things.
Jack: 哦对这玩意怎么没拍卖呢
Jack: Oh right, why didn’t we auction this?
Jake: 这销售销售有问题
Jake: There are issues with sales.
Jack: 销售销售
Jack: Sales, sales.
Jake: 销售销售出问题了
Jake: Sales had problems.
Jake: 销售有东西滞销了
Jake: Sales got stuff stuck.
Jack: 销售销售压根就没有销
Jack: Sales, sales, didn’t sell at all.
Jack: 滞销的问题
Jack: The problem of unsold items.
Jake: 哎呀踢到狗了
Jake: Oops, kicked the dog.
Jake: 对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Jack: 可怜的狗狗嗯
Jack: Poor doggie, huh.
Jake: 哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake: 要帮忙吗
Jake: Need some help?
Jake: 来帮你一下
Jake: Let me help you.
Jake: 帮你开个灯
Jake: I'll turn on a light for you.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵很重要
Jake: Haha, it's very important.
Lucia:你怎么跟加GBT一样啊
Lucia: Why are you acting like GPT?
Jake: CHAT GPT可没这么呆
Jake: CHAT GPT isn't this dumb.
Jack: 加GBT没有这么
Jack: GPT isn't this...
Jake:确实
Jake: 哈说到做到
Jake: Haha, I keep my promises.
Jake: 哎呀还有娃哈哈
Jake: Ah, there's also Wahaha.
Jake: ad钙奶
Jake: AD calcium milk.
Jake: 这这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Jake: 这哪来的呀
Jake: 我怎么没有印象
Jake: I don't remember this.
男嘉宾:今天突然就出现在这了
Male Guest: It just appeared here today.
男嘉宾:这是不是和你那个你那屋那是同款
Male Guest: Isn't this the same model as the one in your room?
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我那屋比这结实多
Jake: Mine is much sturdier.
Jake: 哎这个咱能爬上去就爬上去
Jake: Hey, if we can climb up, we should climb up.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 下班愉快
Jake: Have a nice off-duty.
Jake: 你们下回就
Jake: Next time you'll...
Jake: 你们下回就动物园见了是吧
Jake: Next time you'll meet at the zoo, right?
Jake: 动物园见
Jake: See you at the zoo.
Jake: 哦好嘞
Jake: Oh, alright.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Violet: 他们下来了吗
Violet: Did they come down?
Jake: 他们还没有
Jake: They haven't yet.
Jake: 我靠充电宝他妈扔这了
Jake: Damn, they left the power bank here.
Jake: 我靠真牛逼
Jake: Damn, that's impressive.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎送您到门口
Jake: I'll walk you to the door.
Jake: 送您到哎
Jake: Walk you to the... hey.
Jake: 怎么啥呀这是
Jake: What's this all about?
Jack: 要要不我们几个结个伴
Jack: How about we team up?
Jake: 可以我觉得可以
Jake: Sure, I think that's good.
Jake: 我觉得可以
Jake: I think that's good.
Jake: 你们结个伴
Jake: You guys team up.
Jake: 要不你们有几个人
Jake: How many of you are there?
Jake: 已经坐不下了
Jake: There's no more room.
Violet: 已经坐不下了
Violet: There's no more room.
Jake: 已经坐不下了
Jake: There's no more room.
Jake: 1234
Jake: 5
Jake: 确实五个人
Jake: It's really five people.
Jake: 对他们他们有一辆车
Jake: Right, they have a car.
Jake: 但是他们要走五个人
Jake: But they need to fit five people.
Nicous: 没事没事
Nicous: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 但是
Jake: But...
Nicous: 发车快快快
Nicous: Hurry, hurry, let's go!
Shure: 他不抽他不抽
Shure: He doesn't smoke, he doesn't smoke.
Shure的女友:随便随便随便
Shure's GF: Whatever, whatever, whatever.
Shure的女友:都行都行都行都行
Shure's GF: Anything is fine, anything is fine.
Nicous: 拿出来拿出来
Nicous: Take it out, take it out.
Shure的女友:我都行
Shure's GF: I'm okay with anything.
Nicous: 最好的
Nicous: The best one.
Shure的女友:你摸吧你
Shure's GF: You choose, you.
Shure: 谢斌主你跟谁一伙
Shure: Thanks Binzhu, who are you with?
Shure: 你跟谁一伙
Shure: Who are you with?
Shure: 谢斌主
Shure: Thanks Binzhu.
Nicous: 我跟中国好女人
Nicous: I'm with the good women of China.
Shure的女友:no
Shure's GF: No.
Nicous: 我跟中国航母一伙
Nicous: I'm with the Chinese aircraft carrier.
Shure的女友:不要担心修的孙
Shure's GF: Don't worry, Shun's son.
Shure: 我跟你讲你要抽我
Shure: I'm telling you, if you draw me.
Shure: 今天不留你在这了
Shure: I'm not leaving you here today.
Nicous: OK跟我们走吧
Nicous: OK, come with us.
Nicous: 包住你了
Nicous: We've got you covered.
Nicous: 大大哥
Nicous: Big brother.
Nicous: 我给你滴啊
Nicous: I'll light it for you.
Nicous: 我灭了来来
Nicous: I'll put it out, come on.
小黄: 大哥
Nicous: Big brother.
Shure的女友:我去
Shure's GF: I'm going.
Nicous: 大哥我给你点火
Nicous: Big brother, I'll light it for you.
Nicous: 来大哥
Nicous: Come on, big brother.
Nicous: 大哥哎
Nicous: Big brother, hey.
Nicous: 大哥我给你点火
Nicous: Big brother, I'll light it for you.
Nicous: 我们给中国航母一哈哈哈哈
Nicous: Let's give it up for the Chinese aircraft carrier, hahaha.
Jake: 航母是什么
Jake: What's an aircraft carrier?
Shure: 不知道
Shure: No idea.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha.
Nicous: 就宁让肺部破坏洞
Nicous: It’s just, rather let your lungs get damaged.
Nicous: 不让航母生锈
Nicous: Than let the aircraft carrier rust.
Nicous: 只要我抽一个
Nicous: As long as I smoke one.
Nicous: 航母就嘎嘎接
Nicous: The aircraft carrier is fine.
Jake: 哦你捐钱呢是吧
Jake: Oh, you're donating money, right?
Jake: 捐钱呢是吧
Jake: Donating money, right?
Jake: 哦为国为国做贡献呢是吧懂了
Jake: Oh, contributing to the country, I get it.
Jake: 国家卫士
Jake: National guardian.
Nicous: 怎么样这个
Nicous: How about this?
Jake: 怎么又唱起来了
Jake: Why are you singing again?
Nicous: 30分钟了
Nicous: It's been 30 minutes.
Nicous: 他响了
Nicous: It rang.
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Nicous: 刚找不着刚刚
Nicous: Couldn't find it just now.
Jake: 什什么响了
Jake: What rang?
Nicous: 刚才找不到
Nicous: Couldn't find it earlier.
Nicous: 找不到找不到那个麦克风
Nicous: Couldn't find the microphone.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh.